There's a wall in the Saharan desert
that's 16 times longer
than the Berlin Wall.
It's surrounded by 7 million landmines
and it divides the people who were
promised a vote 50 years ago.
That vote never happened.
And the world has decided that's
perfectly acceptable.
This is the story of how international
law died in the desert.
In 1884, Spain colonized the Western
Sahara during the Berlin Conference,
when European power sat around the table
and carved up Africa.
For 90 years, Spain
controlled the territory.
About 74,000 indigenous Sahrawis lived
there, nomadic Berber and Arab peoples,
whose tribes had existed for centuries.
By 1974, Spain wanted out.
They conducted a census to identify who
could vote and promised a referendum.
The plan was simple, that the Sahrawis
choose their own future,
either independence or integration with a
neighboring country.
Morocco had other plans.
King Hassan II claimed Western Sahara had
always belonged to Morocco.
His argument was based on Baya, religious
allegiance that some Saharan tribes had
historically shown to Moroccan sultans.
So Morocco did something unusual.
They asked the International Court of
Justice to rule on their claim just
before Spain could hold a referendum.
On October 16th, 1975, the International
Court of Justice delivered its opinion.
The court acknowledged that yes, some
tribes had shown allegiance to Moroccan
sultans centuries ago.
But the ruling was explicit.
These historical ties do not establish
any tie of territorial sovereignty
between the territory of Western Sahara
and the kingdom of Morocco.
Morocco had no legal claim.
Hours later, King Hassan II appeared on
television and announced the Green March.
The timing wasn't coincidental.
Hassan had survived two assassination
attempts in four years.
His country was in economic crisis.
He desperately needed to
unite Moroccans behind something.
21 days after the court ruled against
him, 350,000 unarmed Moroccan civilians
walked across the border.
Hassan told them they were Mujahideen,
holy warriors
recovering stolen Moroccan land.
It was brilliant political theater.
Here's what he didn't mention.
Just months earlier, a UN mission had
visited the Western Sahara and found an
overwhelming consensus among Saharans in
favor of independence and opposing
integration with any neighboring country.
The mission identified the Polisario
Front, a Sahrawi independence movement
founded in 1973, as the dominant
political force in the territory.
Morocco invaded anyway.
On November 14, 1975, Spain signed the
Madrid Accords with
Morocco and Mauritania.
Spain was weak.
Franco had just died and
they wanted out of Africa.
So they handed administrative control to
Morocco and Mauritania, then left.
The United Nations never
recognized this transfer.
Under international law, you cannot
transfer sovereignty over a territory
without the consent of its people.
But by then, Moroccan troops already
controlled the western
two-thirds of the territory.
Mauritania took the southern third.
Tens of thousands of
Sahrawis fled into the desert.
They ended up in refugee
camps near Tindouf, Algeria.
The camps were supposed to be temporary.
War broke out.
The Polisario Front fought both Morocco
and Mauritania for years.
In 1979, Mauritania withdrew after
suffering military defeats.
Morocco immediately annexed the territory
Mauritania had abandoned.
Between 1980 and 1987, Morocco built a
fortified wall across
the entire territory.
2,700 kilometers long, surrounded by
landmines, manned by over 100,000 troops,
the wall divided
Western Sahara into two zones.
Morocco controlled 70 percent, the areas
with cities, phosphate
mines and fishing ports.
The Polisario Front
controlled 30 percent of empty desert.
But Morocco didn't just build walls, they
implemented a settlement policy.
They relocated hundreds of thousands of
Moroccan citizens into Western Sahara,
offering subsidies, jobs and housing.
Sounds familiar?
It's called creating facts on the ground.
Change the demographics.
Build infrastructure.
Wait long enough.
Then claim any
alternative is impractical.
By 2025, Moroccan settlers outnumber
indigenous Sahrawis about 2 to 1.
Under the Fourth Geneva Convention,
transferring civilians into occupied
territory is illegal.
This is the same principle that makes the
Israeli settlements in
the West Bank illegal.
Meanwhile, Morocco
began extracting resources.
The bukra, phosphate mine and fishing
rights worth hundreds
of millions annually.
Agriculture land, some of it owned
personally by King Mohammed VI.
Between 1976 and 2015, Morocco extracted
an estimated 5.6 billion in resources
from Western Sahara.
In 1991, Morocco and the Polisario Front
agreed to a UN supervised ceasefire
and referendum.
The deal was clear.
Sahrawis would vote to choose between
independence and
integration with Morocco.
The UN established Miniroso, a
peacekeeping mission, to organize it.
The referendum was
scheduled for January 1992.
It never happened.
The problem was voter eligibility.
Who counts as Sahrawi?
Spain's 1974 census listed 74.000 people.
Morocco submitted applications for
120.000 additional voters.
By the early 2000s, UN officials
concluded that the vast majority of
Morocco's applicants
couldn't prove they
had the right to vote.
That's when Morocco declared the
referendum unrealistic.
In 2001, King Mohammed VI officially
rejected the referendum
in a televised speech.
Instead, Morocco proposed autonomy under
Moroccan sovereignty.
The vote promised in 1975 was dead.
Morocco had
successfully run out the clock.
So why did the
international community let this happen?
Because Morocco became
too valuable to alienate.
Morocco controls the Strait of Gibraltar,
a critical maritime choke point.
They provide counter-terrorism
intelligence that
European countries depend on.
After the 2015 Paris attacks, Moroccan
intelligence was essential
to finding the ringleader.
But here's the critical factor.
Morocco serves as
Europe's migration barrier,
stopping hundreds of thousands of African
migrants from reaching European shores.
When countries tried to challenge them,
Morocco demonstrated their leverage.
In 2021, Spain attempted to honor
European court rulings.
Morocco's response was immediate.
They opened migration routes, and 10,000
people poured into the Spanish enclave of
Ceuta in a single day.
Within months, Spain reversed its
position and endorsed
Morocco's autonomy plan.
France followed in 2024, the United
Kingdom shifted in 2025, and
then there's the United States.
In 2020, Donald Trump recognized Moroccan
sovereignty over Western Sahara entirely.
The deal was simple.
Morocco normalizes relations with Israel,
and America recognizes their claim.
The calculation has
always been transactional.
Supporting Morocco
provides concrete benefits,
intelligence sharing, migration control,
and trade opportunities.
Supporting the Sahrawis provides none.
Here's what's remarkable though.
The same countries that condemn Israeli
settlements as illegal
under the Geneva Conventions are
endorsing nearly
identical Moroccan settlements
using nearly identical justifications.
Change the demographics, build
infrastructure, wait long enough,
and then call any
alternative impractical.
The difference isn't
legal, it's political.
Today, 173,600 Sahrawi refugees live in
camps near Tindouf, Algeria
Three generations
have been born in exile.
In August 2022, the World Food Programme
cut rations by 75%.
Refugees who once received 17 kilograms
of food monthly now
receive less than five.
Since 1975, over 500
Sahrawis have been disappeared,
taken into secret
detention without charges or trial.
In 1991, Morocco released 300 prisoners
who had been held for up to 19 years.
The government had
persistently denied holding them.
520 people are still missing.
In May 2021, Moroccan security forces
raped a prominent
activist named Sultana Khaya.
Human Rights Watch and Amnesty
International documented it.
She's been under house
arrest since November 2020.
The world said nothing.
brahim Hussein Leibeit was 19 when he lost
half his left leg stepping on a landmine.
He was trying to get close enough to the
wall to throw a pebble to the other side,
a symbolic gesture of crossing a barrier
that shouldn't exist.
When asked if he
regretted it, Ibrahim said,
"I would gladly lose my other leg if it
would mean my country could be free."
The ceasefire that held
from 1991 to 2020 collapsed.
Fighting resumed.
The referendum promised
for 1992 will never happen.
Morocco won by waiting.
They changed facts on the ground
than international law could respond.
And the world decided
that was acceptable.
Because in the end, this isn't a story
about law or justice.
It's a story about power.
Morocco has it.
The Sahrawis don't.
And that's the only thing that matters.